Excellence is mundane Excellence is in
the tiny things Excellence is in waking
up 50 minutes earlier than the day
before Excellence is changing our habits
one at a time Excellence are the times
when we are working every day in small
incremental steps to reach our goals but
what do we do when these goals seems to
be moving further and further away and
our steps feel heavier until we are
unable to lift our feet usually in these
moments we try to speed up wake up
earlier push more feel the morning on
our faces however if the original Drive
is missing the final push may stop us
all together so hi I'm Schloss FASA
second year PhD student in computational
neuroscience and in this video I really
want to talk about the topic motivation
and how we kind of lose and get our
motivation to achieve excellent
performance and for me motivation is
really this feeling that I want to push
forward and achieve my goals without any
stress or strenuous activity that is
needed for requiring these goals so
motivation is almost this feeling of
effort listeners and if you are also
struggling with focus and motivation but
you really want to achieve your goals I
think this video could really help you
as I will discuss three topics or three
methods that I always use to get through
these periods and really help me achieve
the goals that I want to achieve but
lately for me focus and motivation has
been far few in between and I think that
is partly to do to this phenomenon
called the second year slump so the
second year slump is the time during the
middle of your PhD or a big project when
you feel like you have lost your way
it's a time where most students have a
massive crisis of confidence both linked
to their own skills and whether they can
ever complete their projects but also
linked to the project itself and whether
it even has any value it's a pretty dark
and lonely time where Everything feels
really hard and is very isolating and
this is by girly microbiologists and I
think the biggest contributor to this
type of second year slump or this type
of feeling is because in general our
progress is not linear so it's not that
if we take one step in the right
direction we will necessarily reach our
goal faster it could be that this step
is to the left to the right or even a
step backwards and before we make this
step we don't really know if it will
bring us to the goal that we want to
reach so the first thing I want to talk
about are Keystone habits and changing
your Keystone habits so in general there
are many books about habits there's tiny
habits Atomic habits the power of habits
amongst others and I personally love all
of these books but today I really want
to dive into one main topic and that's
Keystone habits so Keystone habits are
usually habits that trigger other
processes to follow up from these
Keystone habits so if you do these
Keystone habits the other things that
you have to do to reach your goal feel a
lot easier and feel a lot smoother so
what I've noticed that usually when we
want to try to reach a goal and get
there as fast as possible we try to
really adjust our Behavior pretty
drastically but usually these drastic
changes are not that sustainable so for
example if you have a big exam coming up
a drastic change would be like I'm gonna
study every day for 10 hours and I will
do this for the next month such that I
can get an A and I think in general this
is not super sustainable so a better way
that for me really works is to look at
my Keystone habits and only change this
or only do this in the day so to
identify your Keystone habit it is
pretty easy you just think about the
goal that you want to achieve so for
example for me right now it's to write a
paper or finish up a paper and then you
list down all the things that you have
to do so during the day I would have to
write for an hour for example make some
code look at the figures Etc and then I
think about all the habits that I could
add to my life that could help me
achieve this goal so for example that
could be going to the uni in the morning
or writing for an hour every day or
every time I come home program a little
bit and then I look at all the these
habits and this is really free flow so
put all the habits on there and then I
look at all these habits and I pick down
the one staff for me are really the
habits that will probably benefit me the
most in achieving this goal and these
are done the habits that I'm gonna focus
on for the next few weeks to really
solidify those in my daily life so for
example right now what I've noticed is
if I go early in the morning to UNI my
day feels a lot smoother and I get a lot
more done so this is for me a really a
keystone habit so the second thing that
can help you if you lost your motivation
is to really try to remember why you
started for me for my PhD this sometimes
helps a lot and I try to list down I
have a notion page for all the reasons
that I started my PhD and then every
time my PhD feels really hard or feels
really against me I go over this list
and see if the things or the reasons why
I started my PhD are still valid
nowadays so I think for me the things
that my PhD allowed me to to do is to
really satisfy a part of me that's
really curious and this curiosity is
something that I don't think I can
explore in any other type of field
except for research and I have this
really long list but it's pretty
personal of all the reasons why I'm
doing my PhD but in general if you're
working on a really difficult project I
would recommend to beforehand set up a
list why you want to finish these
projects because there will be moments
during your journey that you will lose
motivation and during those periods
looking at the reasons that you started
this project in the first place or
started this bachelor or started this
PhD will really help you get over these
little humps or losses of motivation so
the last thing I want to talk about if
you're really fatigued and you have lost
a lot of motivation it could be a period
that you're really in need of deep
relaxation and deep relaxation I kind of
quantify as Hobbies or projects that are
outside of your work or outside of your
main projects that really gives you
energy so this could be something really
creative or this could be reading books
because I think a lot of us that are
scientists live with science on our mind
24 7. however if we look at the lives of
many brilliant scientists we see that
they balance their work with other
intellectual or creative Pursuits so for
example Einstein played the violin and
from the age of 13 he was said to be a
particular fan of Mozart sonatas and he
loved studying the compositions and I
think you can see this actually with a
lot of scientists that they don't only
focus on science but they have a lot of
other creative Pursuits on the side that
really for them spark curiosity and joy
so if you are a little bit unsure what
for you Sparks Joy or creativity outside
of your studies and or work because
sometimes we tend to forget these things
one really brilliant idea that I got
from the book second brain is to ask
your family and friends what you were
obsessed with as a kid because usually
what you were obsessed with as a kid is
still something that's kind of inherent
to you that has an intrinsic motivation
that isn't modeled by outside
motivations so I asked my mom in the
weekend what I was really motivated by
as a kid and she told me that I just
really liked learning new things that
were super random so as a kid I was for
example really obsessed with vegetables
I found vegetables really interesting
and wanted to learn everything about it
but this interest only lasted for about
a month and then I became really
interested in tennis and then I again
switched and I kind of still noticed
this that I really personally enjoy the
beginning of a Learning Journey I just
find almost any kind of topic really
interesting and fascinating but if you
ask your parents and or friends what you
were obsessed with as a kid it could be
something really specific or it could be
a general feeling so yes I hope you will
find something that is outside of your
work or outside of your main projects or
interest that can kind of give you
motivation in a field outside of your
studies because I think sometimes if we
find something outside of our studies
that we really enjoy that usually Sparks
a curiosity or creativity back into our
own work so I hope you enjoyed this
really short video and that you learned
something and otherwise see you next
week bye